ashley tisdale whose tv throwbacks are
reaching a whole new audience
imagine having everything we have been
loving your tick tocks during all this
you do the the workouts even to like
your high school musical dances
i completely had no idea what those
dance moments were i was like i've gotta
watch this
and then like that was when my husband
saw like for the first time
like the ending of high school musical
while ashley's reliving her high school
musical days she's also keeping tabs on
her former co-stars like
zac efron i missed you during vacation
one thing everybody's been binging
is zac efron's netflix show down to
earth
i binged it too it was cool to see him
do something that he was really
passionate about
another project ashley's reliving right
now the hit animated series phineas and
ferb
five years after the last episode aired
ashley is bringing her character candace
back in the new disney plus feature
phineas and ferb the movie candace
against the universe
[Music]
most of the original cast is returning
but just getting the movie done was a
bit of a challenge because of the
pandemic i heard everyone got sent
like a diy at-home voiceover kit
they sent us this uh big black suitcase
that
looked like something the government
would send you i'm really fortunate
because my husband is a composer
so he has a studio i think he thought it
was cool to like see
me come to life as my character it's
still there look
look well actually it turns out ashley's
not that different from her character
in real life i definitely would spy on
my sister with boys
and i would report to my parents oh you
are so
busted mom we actually just wanted to
get her in trouble
you